chapitre 1 je dois lui avouer ça fait
une bonne heure que je suis devant mon
pc est éteint
je pense trop à lui à ce que je ressens
pour lui pourtant j'aime les filles du
moins je crois
il a toujours été là pour me soutenir et
ça me touche beaucoup mes sentiments
envers lui on grandit de jour en jour
lui aussi sort avec des filles
donc je suis sûr de me prendre un taux
de sa part si jamais joué à vous mes
sentiments huila que mon téléphone au
anna magnani entre parle de lui
allo elle salue lucas me dit il salut ça
va super et toi me demande-t-il beaucoup
mieux merci à tant mieux ça te dit de
manger une bonne pizza devant un film
tous les deux le propre au style
ah oui pourquoi pas super à ce soir 19h
chao dit il pis il a raccroché
on va être que tous les deux et je sens
que je vais bégayer rougir toute la
soirée je vais me changer mettre un jean
et un simple t-shirt iron man
ça fera le faire je sors de chez moi et
me dirige vers ma voiture direction
l'appartement diplôme j'ai hâte il
arrive je tiens plus en place
comme si j'attendais un cadeau alors que
c'est lucas j'attends la célèbre demeure
porte et me dirige vers celle ci je
l'ouvré missouri il aborde sourire
craquant entre n'attend pas que je te le
dise tu tu es comme chez toi
khouildi la merde
aa oui merci il s'installe sur le canapé
et je lui montre sur ma télé les films à
voir du connaissant il va vouloir
regarder
avengers ça dérange pas nous
demande-t-il en me regardant de ses
magnifiques yeux bleus dit non non
t'inquiète pas dis-je en allant chercher
les pizzas on commence alors le film
tout en dévorant de pizzas et la soirée
le fait que ce chapitre 2 n'est utile le
film est terminé
comme par hasard lucas est scotché à son
téléphone je dis ça mais moi aussi je
suis accro alors je fais de même sauf
que mon regard dsk est resté pardon sauf
que mon regard est resté scotché sur le
cac qui par moments vous regarde
furtivement d'un air gêné puis rogie
salle heureux tuilerie bleus manquera
quand quand j'y pense
il faudrait que je suis ici pour mieux
régner mois et le cas ouais j'suis pas
dit mais mélanie et moi c'est terminé
je suis désolé bros
le truc du broco bras battant otakette
c'est moi qui ai mis fin à notre
relation
ah ouais je peux savoir pourquoi alors
là je ne m'y attendais pas le gao chars
je me suis je comprends molosses la
crique au pardon alors là je m'attendais
pas lucas au chat tu suis obligé de lui
mentir je ne vais pas le dire que je
laime alors qu'il était revenu et qu'il
me dira non ah oui ben je l'aimé plus
adacore c'est un outil adacore tesla et
les barriques watts et je ne pense pas
qu'il y est je pense pas qu'il ait gober
mais tant pis je ne suis pas prêt à lui
avouer mes sentiments
j'ai du mal à y croire cyprien se
séparer de mélanie après tant de temps
passé ensemble c'est juste un gars
génial pour moi c'est une véritable
porte qui s'ouvre je me concentre à
nouveau sur mon téléphone faisant mine
de regarder des trucs le regard de
cyprien est insistant ce qui me gêne
énormément et me fait rougir
il n'arrêtera donne jamais de me
regarder ou quoi s'ils prennent le parti
de me fixer se plaît tu me fait flipper
là oh pardon hein volga maintenant
attendu entre nous je suis dois je
regarde à mon tour mais furtivement aux
4,8 montre je me colle à lui pour
regarder le tweet qui veut montrer
veiller dans l'écran je relève la tête
pour lui faire une remarque mais
d'élèves ne sont plus qu'à quelques
centimètres culte de l'autre
je rougis énormément suite à ce
rapprochement sa main vient se glisser
sur ma joue ses lèvres se rapproche
dangereusement de mois et viennent se
poser sur les miennes je ne recule pas
au contraire bien intensifier ce baiser
en mettant mes mains sur son cou il se
retire et maigre regard de dernière
interrogateurs toi tu ne pas rembourser
tu tues mais tu m'aimes
je lui répondis par un tendre baiser
qu'il approfondit en collant de corée un
autre puis on se sépare à contrecoeur
sais rien
depuis je suis célibataire on s'est
beaucoup rapproché très vite tours à
jenson petit des sentiments à ton égard
je t'aime voilà il me regarde avec
beaucoup de tendresse
le premier bras aux enceintes est en
cours on y déposant aussi un doublé
c'est quoi cette phrase de m la soirée
se termine doucement je reste dormir
chez lui
on part se coucher je retire tout sauf
mon cas son tee shirt comme l'est
d'ailleurs on s'allonge et nous collons
l'un à l'autre en nous laissant guider
dans les bras de morphée fin et voilà
les gens c'est bien point de cette
superbe animation un immense merci à
lungi bush qui s'est donné pour la
réaliser n'hésitez pas à aller voir sa
chaîne youtube en cliquant sur la fille
juste là et on s'entend tv dans une
prochaine vidéo sur demande
pissas